thank you
so eurom we've sat down several times
over the years and one of the things
that I'm really interested in right now
is figuring out how Israel can help
America because clearly you guys have
some issues here nobody's denying that
but America has a whole lot of issues
and we seem to export issues across the
world we have you know political
division we have this blue State Red
State situation we're we seem to be
lacking a national cohesion at the
moment and one thing that I'm seeing
very strongly in Israel is despite a
certain Division and this judicial
reform situation and religious and
secular and all of those things there is
still something that's binding this
country together and I have not been
here in eight years and when I see the
difference
of Jerusalem from eight years ago it is
unbelievable and I mean unbelievable
going in the right direction where so
many of our big cities and this is the
biggest city in the country are going in
the other direction so I actually don't
want to focus on the problems what what
is right here right now
or have I completely misdiagnosed it I
don't think I have on this beautiful day
and I should mention we're probably on
the best real estate in the entire
country right now yeah sure always
always a pleasure to meet you next to
the hotel and the Temple Mount not bad
you know
that's that's our past and that's our
future right here in you know in one one
camera shot no I think I I basically
agree with you Israel always has
problems every country has problems but
um overall if you look at the trajectory
for the last uh 15 20 years
um
Israel is doing immensely well I mean
let's let's consider 20 years ago Israel
was uh had a terrific energy problems
now we're we're a net exporter of energy
due to Natural Gas fines and maybe even
oil fine soon I should pause you for a
moment what people heard back there that
was the Muslim call to prayer which how
many times a day does that go five times
a day five times they got us we only go
three
so people will be hearing that in the
background as we as we do this here in
the Jewish state of Israel the Muslim
call to prayer obviously is still
respected it's part of being in the
Middle East right yeah um so look we
we're we're energy exporters we're about
to start
exporting gas to the Europeans
because they don't have natural
resources yeah that's a whole other
thing we're a water exporter we have 15
years of successful uh
pioneering desalination so so that you
know 20 years ago we were still being
told don't you know take short showers
and now we have all the water we want we
sell to other people and financially
Israel just uh it keeps on growing we
were hit less than just about any other
country in 2008 by the uh by the world
economic shock so you know all of these
these material aspects are
the countries just doing beautifully and
if you switch to looking at foreign
affairs
again 20 years ago uh we had
[Music]
a hostile Arab world today thanks to
Trump and Netanyahu we have
a peace peace five new peace peace
treaties every time you go to the
airport they're they're just taking off
to take you to take people to the gulf
and bring people from the Gulf and you
know that's a whole a whole new
a new relationship with uh with with the
entire Middle East so there are problems
there too but it's improving it if I I
think you you zero in on the most
important thing the most important thing
is is you know for for any any countries
how many children are people having
because if if people people aren't
having children it means they're not
investing in the future they don't
believe in the future they have no
confidence in the future and here in
Israel the um the the Jewish birth rate
has been going up
um steadily for for over 20 years at at
this point Jews are having as many
children as Arabs and if the trans
continued Jews will be having more
children than Arabs if you can if you
can imagine this
Israel's Israel's per woman birth rate
is approaching twice the birth rate in
the United States wow what is that
that's about it's like it's it's over
three at this point it's over three
children per woman and that you know
these numbers are they're not just one
sec sector of the population the you
know the the most secular uh Tel avivi's
still have more children than than
Americans do or any almost any European
country so that's what I'm interested in
that's the thing that I think maybe
Israel can export to America that we're
missing in the because again we can talk
about the divisions here but despite the
external threats which I guess aren't as
or not I guess I understand are less
than what they used to be not gone
obviously with Iran but are what they
are and then now there's some internal
stuff but still the the driving thing
the family thing I mean you you run the
national conservatism conference really
all about that why is that working here
what what is it that I can bring back to
America and say guys there's this tiny
jersey size place across the world that
has something that that can help us fix
our our national problem right look
Israelis are are uh connected to reality
you know in in part it's because uh of
the the nature of Judaism which is a
very down to earth religion in a lot of
ways and in part it's it's the
environment of of uh of having to deal
with constant security issues
um and uh both of these two things
um create a a population that is
um you know you can say tribal people
say that you know use that term in a
negative sense here I'd like to say it
in a positive sense is uh
Israeli Jews you know are despite the
fact that they're divided into all sorts
of different sub-groups and competitions
just like everywhere else but the uh the
over the overall feelings feeling a
family it's um it's uh we have a
religious inherent inheritance that says
that you know God promises that even if
we're at the farthest corner of the
Earth this is from Deuteronomy
um even for at the farthest corner of
the earth God is going to bring us back
and the the the the project of of
bringing the Jews back to our ancient
Homeland is something that you know some
people are really excited about it all
the time and some people you know
they're a little bit more cynical but
but the overall feel of the country is
you know is is just that is you know
we're coming home we're fulfilling a
Biblical promise and by the way people
remember that you know even if they
don't believe in God they remember that
it's it's important to them that we're
fulfilling the promise and um and
they're very realistic about what we
need to do in order to be able to do
that so people serve in the military you
know whenever there's a
serious military situation that the Army
is flooded with volunteers for people
who are you know who who don't even owe
being drafted they call up and say what
can I do because they they know it's up
to them if they let the country down
then there's not going to be a country
here so people people serve in the
military I've served in the military
um I have sons and daughters who've
served in different Security Services of
the country and
um
and uh you know it's it's the same kind
of thing about about voting and
participating in our democracy and it's
the same kind of thing about uh having
children like you know I I know a lot of
Liberals are real cynical about this you
know if you say uh well you know if
somebody has children for the sake of
his country then you obviously doesn't
love his children I I think it's a I
think that's a I'm sorry I think it's a
complete Croc I think it's the the
opposite is if you have something to
live for that you care about and you you
want to bring children into that thing
that you're living for and that you care
about then your children when they're
they're born into that then then they've
got they've got an inheritance they've
got you know a a purpose in life now
they of course they can reject it if
they want to but for most children it
you know that that's the healthiest
thing is to is to grow up into you know
into a struggle where from the first
moment you know people are saying you
know you're not nobody you're important
you know God brought you back here to
Israel in order to rebuild this this
land and we need you I mean that that
gives the children a sense of strength a
sense of belonging a sense of place it
makes them in a lot of ways morally more
resilient again I'm not saying that we
have no problems with lots of problems
but if we're comparing to America or
Europe right now you know the these are
kids growing up with a purpose and
they're going to get married they're
going to have kids because they believe
in that purpose so it's interesting to
be sitting here and you're giving me
very much what the city's about they're
sort of the the philosophical and and
religious and cultural and then you're
also giving me a very real world example
literally multiply and combining those
two things seems to be the solution
um so how do we how do we get that to
America how do we get that message not
only to America but you know you're
doing that con and you're you know I'm
going to Hungary next week which is a
real Bastion of those ideas they seem to
be really taking root in Eastern Europe
but how do we get that to countries I
mean from an American perspective where
we seem so afraid where the woke have
destroyed almost everything that might
have brought us together it's infected
virtually everything and we don't have a
say a national religion that might be
the thing to be the final protection
there well look America America did have
a national religion I mean this is an
important part of this conversation is
that that uh that America not you know
not just culturally but by law according
to the the Supreme Court of the United
States America was a Christian Nation a
Christian people by law up until World
War II and I understand I understand
very very well the you know the the the
reasons why uh after the two World Wars
people people you know were tired of of
that inheritance and they wanted to try
liberalism but at this point look at
this point you've seen liberalism takes
you straight into woke neo-marxism okay
so it takes two generations but the
bottom line is you if you you you rip
the Bible out of the schools you don't
allow people to say say prayers it means
that all the children are going to
school to be brainwashed to think that
their inheritance their religious
political constitutional
inheritance is not important and uh
that's gotta look that's got to be
turned around obviously it's not gonna
you're not going to turn 300 million
people in one step that I mean that
that's clear but there are places in the
United States where
um where either there's a Christian
majority or more likely there's a
pro-christian majority that you could
build where you know where where
different kinds of Christians along with
Orthodox Jews and other people who are
more conservative can can negotiate a a
public culture you know in in certain
states which is going to be more like
the culture in Israel when I say more
like Israel I mean that both the
government and the leading figures who
are not in government and and the
education system and the public will be
more focused on
um well more more focused on knowing
something about the Bible more focused
on uh on uh their purpose and their role
more focused on a mission of uh turning
I don't know let's say the State of
Florida into a uh in to something like
the like what Hungary is now I'm not
saying you have to agree with everything
that Orban does but I'm saying that that
the the Hungarian leadership and much of
its people at this point they they look
at Israel and they want to be like
Israel and they're create recreating a
kind of a sense of mission that is in a
sense it's it's uh it's israeli-like and
that has to happen that needs to start
happening in certain places in the
United States once there's you know two
or three states they don't have to be
exactly the same that of different
models where where you know people are
focused you know we want to have a
future we're going to have children
we're going to serve in the military
we're we're going we're we're going to
to uh to to teach teach religion as our
cultural inheritance even if we're not
100 Believers with it
we need two or three places in America
that look like that I think that as soon
as those things exist people normal
people you know the left look the left
is always going to say oh it's Iran your
fascist right forget them I'm saying
that normal people will will find
themselves saying you know I'd just much
rather live in a place like that I I see
the you know the ruin and the
devastation that these woke neo-marxists
are are are bringing I wanna I want a
normal life and they'll start to realize
that that normal what they're calling a
normal life is actually a life that is
still somewhat within a Biblical
framework which maybe they didn't
realize before so we've discussed this
many times and you've written about this
and you've talked about this a million
times but but somewhat briefly because I
know a certain set of people that maybe
are just hearing you for the first time
they're going to go wait a minute here
I'm watching an orthodox Jew sitting in
Jerusalem basically saying America
should be a Christian Nation what do you
do with the minorities within that so
you sort of said that the Christians and
the ultra the Orthodox Jews could kind
of work together on this what do you how
do you make the room for the atheists
for gay people for Muslims for anyone
that's outside of that within that
structure especially in a place like
America that's truly that's as
Multicultural as you can possibly get
look I think I I think that being
realistic about the situation right now
includes understanding that
um
are not that many Christians at all in
America at this moment who you know
whose goal is to uh to drive out all of
the uh all of the Jews and all of the
the Muslims and all the gays so that
it's impossible for them to live there
that's like like the this uh bogey man
that you know hunts it haunts the the
secular imagination I'm not saying that
historically it's impossible that
something like that could happen but the
the people who are saying this are
people who don't they don't actually
know American Christians they don't
actually understand that you know
Americans are American Christians I mean
they're having the same problems
everybody else is having no it's
infecting everything they're having
problems with their kids and you know
they're more likely to say to you you
know I
most concerned about how my kids stay
Christian then you know to start telling
you how you know the country needs to be
homogeneously Christian so okay so
you'll find some Kooks here and there
but I'm talking about the the the
Practical political people who are going
to be in these negotiations across the
United States almost everywhere I go the
feeling I get is they want Jews they
want Jews to help them they they want
Jews to help them you know not just in
the uh in the instrumental sense of of
uh you know having Jews in my Coalition
will make it easier for you know for for
people to know that I'm not the
Ayatollah but I mean I'm sure there's
some of that but but
well beyond that you know the the
Christian Christians are having
internally a cultural crisis over the
Bible and I I know this because uh 10
years ago I published a book on the
philosophy of the Bible and since then
I've had hundreds of conversations
initiated by by American European
Christians of every possible
denomination and the message is is Just
Uniforms I mean they say look
um the Bible is the most Politically
Incorrect book ever written the attacks
we're losing our children not because of
the you know of the gospel and the New
Testament and Jesus we're losing our
children because we don't know how to
teach the Old Testament and they're
asking Jews to come and help them
explain the Old Testament which which by
the way is something really important
for America right now the the Old
Testament is the is the it's the it's
the classical source for the idea of a
nation of one nation under God that's
that's a biblical it's a Biblical idea
there's no Greek or Roman source for
that one nation under God that you know
that powerful American thought it's
actually a Biblical thought and so so
what Christians are are asking Jews to
do is help us
help us understand what these stories
are all about why why does why does the
Old Testament which is 80 percent of the
Christian Bible why is it so concerned
with the nation and the independence of
the nation and the inheritance of the
nation what is all of this about tribes
and how how you unify the tribes of a
Nation what is all of this about you
know about uh a nation having borders
um that that you know don't just keep
people up they actually keep they keep
you sane by make helping you understand
that your goal is not to conquer the
rest of the world now you know maybe
we'll we'll teach some stuff to the rest
of the world but but it's not our job to
go conquer the rest of the world it's
it's our job to fix our problems at home
and create a Godly Society or as people
today would say you know a society
people would just want to live in and
that that
um The Return of that to the public
discussion I think from what I've from
from the many many Christians I've seen
across the United States and and and and
toxic laid into the night and trying to
understand what they want what they want
is a place where their children can grow
up Christian and they see Jews certainly
as being able to help them you know you
and I know that with with gays the
situation is a little bit more
complicated not a lot more complicated
because because they want to make sure
that they have space to be able to tell
their you know to tell their children
look this is this is the the normative
path is uh is young man marries a young
woman they want to be able to say that I
don't think which I have no problem with
but it is the normative path but I I
don't I don't think that I don't think
that that has to lead to persecution in
America today I think it's absurd it's
absurd to say that that will lead to
persecution because in any case anybody
running for office on this kind of a
platform is going to be sitting down
with Dave Rubin and saying look let
let's talk I want to I want to say the
things in a way that's not going to
alienate potential voters that's what's
going to happen all right I got I got
one more for you because it's getting a
bit warm out here so as we sit here
let's get away from from politics
completely you live in Jerusalem
um we right before you got up here I was
just standing here looking at the wall
and just everything mount scope is just
the whole thing here and I actually I've
been feeling this incredible sense of
Peace since I've been here everywhere
that I've gone just an incredible sense
of peace and I said to my producer I
said buy an apartment in Jerusalem I
don't know I don't have the Shapiro
money yet I'm working on it oh man but I
said to my producer Phoenix you know I'm
having trouble coming up with like a
word to describe like peaceful okay fine
and he said he said you know it's
everything all at once and I thought
that that was a pretty good description
of this and I wonder what your
description of this would be as someone
that lives here and that that knows the
history but is trying to lead the path
to the Future and all that I I I I I I
think if what it feels like to me is the
center of the world this is this is that
was the other thing that he said
actually this this is where this is
where it began and it's being broadcast
from here and
um and you know people some people can
hear it and some people can't hear it
but look I I'll tell you we we live in
remote which is kind of the outskirts of
the city up on a hill you can over kind
of overlooking the city and
um and when I every Friday night when
the Sun is setting and I walk to Schulte
to the synagogue you know with my boys I
I think of the this Yom Kippur prayer
ashray iron
blessed happy is the eye that got to see
this and the young for prayer it's it's
a two thousand year old prayer talking
about the destruction of Jerusalem and
saying how blessed were those who lived
before us because they got to see
God's presence in Jerusalem as it was
being built and we don't get to see it
for two thousand years and today we do
get to see it we get to see it we we
every Friday night we we see the
descending on the holy city and we see
it being uh rebuilt and it gives hope
because it gives hope for Jews it gives
Hope For All Mankind that you know
something precious that was destroyed
can be restored and we can all take part
in it thank you
see you my friend if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about international issues check out our
International playlist and if you want
to watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell